- The winner is Sidney Poitier.
- Sidney Poitier fracasse
le plafond de verre en 1964
en devenant le premier homme
noir meilleur acteur. Sa prestan
dans "Le Lys des champs"
lui vaut les grands honneurs.
♪ ♪ ♪
GREGORY CHARLES,
artiste multidisciplinaire
- Moi, j- Moi, j- Moi, j- Moi, e
le rencontrer, Sidney Poitier.
J'ai été ému, un peu commeque Me
Richard est décédé parce que
je savais ce qu'il représentait
pour mes grands-parents.
Bahamas, rien ne le prédestinait
à Hollywood. Il migre a-
Unis à l'âge de 15 ans et
intègre l'Actors Studio, une
ANTOINE BENZ, comédien
- C'étur préféré
de ma grand-mère. Ma mère,
la première fois qu'ellait
"Who's coming to dinner".
Donc, pour moi, c'était quelque
chose, quelqu'un que j'ai
toujou
- You watch yourself, black boy.
à son actif, il campe le rôle
d'un médecin noir dans
une Amérique blanche,
transgressant les codes sociaux
L'acteur embrasse la cause
oits civiqoits civiqoits civiqos
aux États-Unis et
incarne même le person
MICHEL COULOMBE,
chroniqueur cinéma
- Quand il est arrivé
à Hdes andes andes andes andes t
volontiers, il tenait un premier
rôle dans un film, qu'il était,
là où il travaillait,
de chaussures.
(applas)s)s)s)s)s)s)
- Il reçoit en 2019 la médaille
présidentielle de la liberté
la plus haute distinctionaux Ét.
FABIENNE COLAS, actrice, fond.
Festival int. fieste encore beae
travail pour les acteurs pour
pouvoir trouver des rôles un peu
moins clichés ou non clichés.
de ce que des gens comme Sidney
Poitier ont faitelques
générations pour continuer
de marcher vers une plus grande
reconnaissance aujourd'hui.
- Ici Jean-Philippe Hugues,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.